[Music]
if we do this we'd be going in
short-handed yeah you mean cuz he killed
all that friend we owe this to everyone
who's not in this room to try
[Music]
it's not about how much we lost it's
about how much we have left
[Music]
wizzy ventures
we can finish this
you trust me I do
[Music]
you could not live with your own failure
where did that bring you
[Music]
back to me
[Music]
tickets on sale now
Gussie was like a thousand years ago I
fought my way out of that cave became
Iron Man
[Music]
we lost I loved you analyst said no more
surprises but I was really hoping to
pull off one last one
but world has changed
none of us
or we can do it is our best
and sometimes the best we can do
sonofa
[Music]
I saw all these people die
I keep telling everybody they should
move on
some do bananas
[Music]
a small chance
we owe this
everyone who's not in this room to try
[Music]
we will
whatever it takes
[Music]
whatever it takes
rather it takes
whatever it takes
[Music]
[Music]
I like this one
[Music]
we lost all of us
the lost friends they lost family today
we have a chance to take it all back we
will whatever it takes
that it takes
whatever it takes imagine if for the
first time our heroes all lost
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is no place today
[Applause]
thanos had his way and half of the
population of the universe has gone
everyone's doing their best to keep
their head above water but it's it's
kind of a losing battle we lost and
we're not used to losing people are kind
of still coming to grips with it
natasha is a little bit hardened from
what she's had to go through they've
truly leveled us not just literally but
morally and emotionally there was no
other way
the fans reaction to the end of infinity
war when half their favorite characters
turn to dust really was indicative of
how emotionally connected the world has
gotten to these characters the good
thing is it's always easier to build
people back up after they've been broken
down and that that's what Marvel is
great at doing its that shred of hope
everyone's looking for and we said no
more surprises but it's really hoping to
pull off one last one
I like this one
[Applause]
some people in move on with us
Matis stay on
hey miss Potts if you find this
recording don't feel bad about this part
of the journey is the end
just for the record being adrift in
space with zero promise of rescue is
more fun that sounds food and water went
out four days ago
officers will run out tomorrow morning
back then when I drift off I will dream
about him it's always you
[Music]
[Music]
thanos did exactly what he said he was
gonna do
he wiped out 50% of all living creatures
we lost all of us
plus friends you lost family
we lost a part of ourselves
this is the fight of our lives this is
gonna work Steve I know it is cuz I
don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't
hi is anyone home this is Scott Lang we
met a few years ago at the airport in
Germany got really big it's just an old
message I know you know that suspect oh
that's me can you buzz me in
[Music]